[Music]
dave i'm thinking about building a house
any suggestions absolutely
definitely got suggestions when you're
thinking about building a house
there's three
and maybe four things
you must do
if you're gonna build a house
maybe five but i'll walk you through
here's what we do okay there's some sub
pieces so three
maybe four the maybe four is if you've
already picked out the property and
bought it
and you've already got your builder
and you're doing kind of an independent
standalone type of a deal
then we will pass on number one but
number one is if you haven't then i
would get a good
buyer's agent realtor at daveramsey.com
click on elp for real estate elp and get
them to represent you through the whole
transaction with the builder help you
navigate with the builder
if you haven't already selected it so if
you're going in where somebody's
building houses a builder's got a
subdivision going and they're doing a
whole bunch of deals and they got houses
popping up everywhere and you're going
to run down there i want that one on
that lot and you haven't done that yet
and yeah i'd get a realtor in your
corner a buyer's agent in your corner
because they'll work as your liaison
during the construction process
and they're going to work their butts
off for their commission i promise you
now
number the the other three are with
everybody okay there are three things
that run a building job a building job
is simply a project it's project
management's all it is
if we're doing a project here developing
a product uh we're writing a book with
chris hogan
on millionaires okay chris hogan's
writing a book on millionaires so that's
a project how do you do that well
projects all need basically three things
need a blueprint
which is how the project is going to be
built what's the house going to be you
need a detailed blueprint that you and
the builder are in agreement on if you
don't already have that while you're
drawing it involve your builder with the
architect so the two of them are working
together to develop the plan
so the architect's not drawing something
stupid that's that's ridiculous to be
built or super expensive because they
went to art class and don't know
anything about building
okay
so you've got to have the balance in
there but if you've already got your
blueprint you got your blueprint that's
thing one
this is one of the three pieces of paper
that manages
a building job the second piece of paper
is do not engage in a building project
without a detailed schedule
a schedule
when we built the homes that we built we
had a spreadsheet
and before we broke ground we knew the
week the trim carpenter was going to
show up we knew the week the painter was
going to show up we knew the week the
roofer was going to show up we knew the
week the grading was going to be done on
this or that all you know with bushes
are going in on this date we're going to
get the co the the certificate of
occupancy on this date and so you've got
you begin with the end in mind on the
schedule
you got your blueprint you got the
schedule that we're going to build it
then you could tell if the builder's off
track because he's building something
that's not on the blueprint or he's off
schedule because weather's been bad or
he hasn't done a good job of keeping the
sub scheduled in
but if you start a house in october and
you know march the 4th the trim
carpenter's supposed to be there you can
already schedule the trim carpenter and
so you don't end up without a dadgum
trim carpenter when you're supposed to
and right now there's a shortage of
labor in the building business and if
you don't have your subs lined up all
the way out you're going to get messed
over on your schedule
so a schedule and a blueprint the third
piece of paper is a budget
it'll budget which we're building to
and when they come in go well we're you
know we can't we can't do this on budget
what do you mean you can't do it on
budget this is the budget this is what
we said
and it keeps you from doing stupid stuff
we're building a house and the decorator
came in and picked out expensive carpet
for the downstairs nobody goes
downstairs much
and she's blowing our whole carpet
budget or flooring budget on this stupid
downstairs carpet
because decorators being a decorator
right i'm like no you're this dave
ramsey building this house kiddo so put
the cheaper carpet downstairs nobody
goes down there anyway and get your dead
gum flooring budget back into because
we're not going a bazillion dollars over
a flooring budget
and so you can build a house on budget
on schedule and then every friday we met
with the builder and we looked at the
blueprint the schedule and the budget
and made sure everything that was done
that week was lining up with all of that
the blueprint the schedule and the
budget the blueprint the schedule and
the budget every friday morning and of
course we had the money lined up so we
paid them every friday morning
and they were able to pay their subs
everybody's happy everything stays on
track we finished the houses early
and under budget
the last two houses we built
can you imagine that
can you imagine building a house for me
how big a pain in the butt that is but
you know what we didn't change 63 things
during the way if you the more change
orders you do the more you're going to
lose your butt it's hard on the builder
it's hard on the subs it's hard on the
schedule it's hard on the budget so make
your mind up and stick with it we did
two three change orders on both houses
i mean almost no change orders
we had some big stuff we got in there we
now this isn't right we got to change
this and we spent and it was on us and
then if it's on me and then mixed in
this is
you as the
person building the stinking house have
to do your job and that is stay ahead of
them on the selections
when you don't go pick out the carpet
you don't go pick out the light fixtures
you don't go pick out the the faucets
you don't go pick out the plumbing
fixtures
months and months and months ahead of
when you need to
then you're slowing the whole thing down
and then you go i had a bad experience
building because you were so freaking
indecisive you were impossible to work
with
every time i give this talk builders all
go god i wish i could get all my people
to do this i'm like you need to demand
it because they're that you stay mad at
your builder and it's your fault
now sometimes builders are
you know
doofuses too like any other business
but if you've got a quality realtor
helping you lead your way through this
and you'll do the budget the blueprint
and the schedule the budget the
blueprint in the schedule manage to that
and you stay ahead of them don't you be
the problem you make your decisions and
a friend of mine took him an extra year
to build his house because he couldn't
get his wife to go pick out the crap
i mean i'm having a fit
hey she couldn't make it remind i'm
gonna kill her what are you talking
about she can't make over my a year
you know when we enjoy the process i
don't enjoy process i want to get it
done
i'm like why am i building the house so
because it's a game i'm building it to
move into it
so you stay ahead of them you you don't
stop them from anything you don't cause
you don't get in the way you don't be a
problem child and don't you go over on
the site and start telling sub stuff's
wrong you're not running the job the
general contractor's run the job if
you're going to go around the site the
only thing you do is take food smile and
tell everybody how wonderful they are
and if you've got a problem you call
your builder you call your general
contractor don't you go telling the
electrician of plugs in the wrong place
they get confused who the boss says then
stay out stay in the chain of command
keep stuff picked out
be a pleasant experience and you will
have a pleasant experience but manage it
like it's a project
i mean people wander around the barn
building these houses and it takes you
forever to get them done
i've got some friends that build houses
here in the area and they refuse to
build houses for people
they build them as specs and when
they're done
you can move in them you can buy them
but they won't they won't they won't let
you be involved because because people
drive the builder crazy
by being indecisive and you know
changing stuff halfway through
and a country music girl in our area was
building a house and
you know she and her decorator changed
everything it took them an extra year
and they spent an extra four million
dollars on an eight million i mean
supposed to be a four million dollar
house end up being eight million dollars
and took him an extra year to build it
all because she changed everything she
built a stupid house twice
as she was going up just change chain
chain chain chain chain chain chain the
whole house is change orders i mean it's
ridiculous no that's that's a dumb way
to build a house it drives everybody
crazy it makes the decorator money makes
the builder money makes the
builder crazy
and makes you the customer crazy and
broke
figure out what you're going to do and
do it have a clear
path
to building a house and you'll have a
great experience if you do that
i have had great experiences now nothing
had no project of that size happens
without glitches and without you having
to have some discussions from time to
time like get your butt and gear kind of
discussion but that's true of managing
any project you gotta line the the labor
sources up
and get things moving
like dude you guys are two weeks behind
how you gonna make it up
i don't know it's been raining well make
it up i mean
i come over here you ain't working it's
two o'clock in the afternoon where the
flip are you
you know you have some of those
discussions right but you don't can't
have those discussions if you're not on
schedule and there's not a schedule
so lay that stuff out and again if
you're starting from scratch get a good
buyer's agent on the front end to walk
you through the process
and use those three things the budget
the blueprint and the schedule the
budget the blueprint the schedule this
is the dave ramsey show